-Our next guest is a very funny
comedian who will be headlining
Carnegie Hall with his show
"Gary Gulman: Born on
Third Base" this Saturday,
November 13th, as part of
the New York Comedy Festival.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Gary Gulman.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome back. How are you?
-It's nice to be back.
I'm terrific.
-Carnegie Hall.
That's a big deal.
-I was hoping
you would bring that up.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, thank you.
Because I don't want it
to just be my manager
and his mother in the audience.
So you're all invited
to Carnegie Hall.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But it must be --
I mean, you know, all comedians
have, through the course of
their career, played
some really low-rent rooms.
It must feel like a real --
This is the right arc to end up
in an iconic room like that.
-It's the first venue
my mother has heard of.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-She's not familiar with
Gutbusters in Tampa,
and the Yuk Yuk's chain.
So this is very exciting.
She can tell all her friends
that I'm performing in a place
they've been familiar with.
-That's fantastic.
And you're living in
New York now.
-Yes.
-You're up in Harlem.
How is it?
-It's fantastic.
The nicest people.
They tell me to have
a blessed day, every day.
I live at 139,000th and...
[ Laughter ]
And Malcolm X.
And people assume --
Well, my wife is a black woman,
so I'm her plus-one.
So they assume that
my neighborhood is gentrified.
But I think they're thinking
further down towards the park.
There's a Whole Foods at
120th and Malcolm Gladwell.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
That's a little bit
more gentrified.
-Yes, and then at 110th, it's
actually Malcolm in the Middle.
-Oh, I understand.
[ Laughter ]
-Those are the famous Malcolms.
-The famous white --
whiter Malcolms.
-I left out
Forbes and McDowell there.
So I apologize to their fans
and estates.
-I want to ask about
the name of your special,
'cause, you know, you did
"The Great Depresh,"
which is absolutely wonderful
and I can't recommend it enough,
where you talked about issues
like anxiety and depression.
What is behind the name
"Born on Third Base"?
-Well, I am very blessed
in that, one,
I suffer from depression during
a time when they could treat it.
And a hundred years ago,
they would just throw me away
and lock the door.
And so I'm very grateful
for that.
Also, I grew up in the '70s
a white male in New England.
So I had advantages.
I'm 6'6", and I ran really fast,
so I was able to get
a scholarship to college.
So I was born on third base.
As poor as we were growing up --
and we were poor --
the great thing was we didn't
feel poor because my father --
a mensch -- and I just want to
keep with the Jewish theme
that we have going here.
[ Laughter ]
-It's a very thematic episode,
yeah.
-This is -- You thought
Hanukkah was early?
No.
It starts before Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
This is incredible.
-This is a pre-Hanukkah party,
yeah.
-Oh, my gosh.
My father had this policy
that made us feel less poor.
He would say, "If there's
something you really want,
just ask for it.
We'll try to find the money."
And then, of course,
like any dad, he would talk us
out of wanting whatever it was
that we wanted.
Like, one year, I wanted to
play hockey,
which, as a New Englander,
you know, it's huge.
-Of course. Yep.
-And so he said, "If you
really want to play hockey,
we'll try to find the money
for you to play this sport
you've shown no potential in."
[ Laughter ]
"Not only have you shown
no potential,
Jews have acquitted themselves
quite poorly in this sport."
And then he pulled out
this sports almanac
with the Hockey Hall of Fame.
He said, "Let's count
the Jewish players."
[ Laughter ]
"Ready? Done.
There are zero Jewish players."
He said, "Just for
a point of comparison,
more Jews have been
the Messiah."
[ Laughter ]
"Do you understand that
you're more likely to be Jesus?
You are more likely
to walk on water
than you are to skate on it."
[ Laughter ]
-How have you -- You know,
I think a lot of people were
interested in how behavior
would change
over the course of this
pandemic, and as we're coming
back to normal, do you --
were your predictions
correct in how people...?
-No.
I really thought people
were going to be nicer.
-Yeah.
-And then I went to Chipotle
soon after.
[ Laughter ]
I go there every other day
anyhow.
It's delicious.
And the people who work there
are so composed
despite the fact that they
deal with this all day long.
Ready? "Corn, corn, black beans,
brown rice."
Just people wagging their finger
at them
to assemble their burrito.
Or their bowl.
[ Laughter ]
You got to be so careful, Seth.
-In this day and age,
you got to be so careful.
-You say burrito, leaving out
the bowl people, the next day,
the people are on -- yes, yes.
-They're like,
"Hey, bowl erasure."
[ Laughter ]
-Right now somebody is angry
because I'm not doing
the manual typewriter correctly.
-Right, there's -- yeah.
-They'll be writing letters.
[ Laughter ]
And so they come in there,
and I just want to tell you,
if you go to Chipotle,
you don't have to point.
They know where the corn is.
[ Laughter ]
You found it.
You don't even work here.
How would they not know
where the corn is?
Just give them the benefit of
the doubt.
Say "corn," and then,
if they look baffled...
[ Laughter ]
...then add the visual aid.
But until -- I'm too sen--
I wouldn't last a shift
at Chipotle.
Somebody would come in, "Corn."
"Oh, is that --
Is that where the corn --
Brenda, I found the corn!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
"It was with
the other toppings.
It's always the last place
you look."
[ Laughter ]
-It's so lovely to see you
again, Gary.
-Same here, Seth.
-Thanks for being here.
Congratulations. Carnegie Hall!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
-For more info on tour dates,
go to garygulman.com.